The way people make money with Claude is
about to change. For the last couple
years, the move was pretty simple. Start
an AI agency, sell some automations, and
build workflows for businesses. [music]
And it worked, but now that window is
closing fast. Every day, more people get
into the market, and it's harder to make
money now. But there is one way to make
money with Claude that's actually
getting easier. It's been flying under
the radar for about a year now, and it's
about to blow up because it solves a
problem that every single business is
running into right now. So, in this
video, I'm going to tell you exactly
what this new opportunity is and how to
get started. So, let's get into it. So,
the AI market has completely blown up
over the last couple years, and there's
more money pouring into the space than
ever before. The big tech companies are
spending tens of billions of dollars
every single month on this stuff.
Amazon, Microsoft, Google, and Meta,
those four companies alone are on pace
to spend around $725 billion combined in
2026. But up until now, if you wanted to
actually make money off of your AI
skills, there was really only one path
being talked about, which was to start
an AI agency. And the problem that I've
been seeing is that maybe 95% of you
guys watching don't want to start your
own AI agency. Most of you are just
learning AI so you don't get left
behind, but you don't want to
necessarily chase clients and run sales
calls all day long. You just want to be
really good at your job and get paid
well for it. And if you would have asked
me a year ago what the solution was for
people like you, I really didn't have a
great answer. But over the last few
months, we've seen a shift where more
and more companies are deciding to solve
their AI problems in house. Because some
companies went out and bought all these
AI tools, they spun up all these little
pilot projects, and most of it went
absolutely nowhere. I'm sure you guys
all heard about that MIT study that
found that 95% of generative AI pilots
inside companies had little measurable
impact on the company's bottom line. So,
they spent all this money, and they
basically got nothing back. And that is
a massive opportunity for people like
you. Somebody has to get inside these
companies and actually drive real
results with AI. Somebody who's focused
only on their business and their
problems. AI consulting has absolutely
taken off over the past year, and the
people doing it are some of the best
paid people in the entire space. So,
while everyone else is racing to the
bottom selling cheap automations, these
people are getting paid for something
completely different. And that's exactly
what you want to become, a Claude AI
consultant. So, what actually is that? A
consultant is just the person who walks
into a business, figures out where
they're losing time and money, and then
uses Claude to fix it. Think about it
like Claude is the car, the company is
the passenger, and you're the driver
using Claude to get them to the
destination that they want, which is
just making more money and saving more
time. So, you might be wondering why
Claude specifically, and the answer to
that is that Claude is just the leader
right now. It's what I run my entire
business on, and it's what I've built
everything you guys have seen on this
channel with. But, the real skill that
you're building here is taking a messy
business problem and getting AI to solve
it reliably, and that skill transfers to
whatever is the next tool that comes up.
And that very well could be open-source
AI models. So, as the space evolves,
especially with these open-source models
getting better and better, you're not
locking yourself into one ecosystem.
You're just starting with what I think
is the best tool out there right now.
And of course, the money flowing into
the space is crazy. AI consulting is
already a market worth billions of
dollars, and depending on which research
firm you ask, it's growing 20-plus
percent every single year. BCG found
that companies plan to basically double
their AI spending in 2026 as a share of
their revenue. And LinkedIn's 2026 list
of the fastest-growing jobs in the US
has AI consultant and strategist ranked
number two, only behind, you guessed it,
AI engineers. So, this opportunity is
very real, but there are two completely
different ways to become a Claude AI
consultant, and they fit two completely
different types of people. So, let me
break down both so you can figure out
which one is for you. Okay, so, the
first type is the freelance consultant.
You work for yourself, you go client to
client, you find their problems, and you
build the fix. And the upside here is
freedom. You can set your own hours, you
can work from anywhere, and there's
really no ceiling on what you can make.
And LinkedIn's data backs this path up,
too. Independent consultants and
strategic advisers just climbed into
their top 10 fastest-growing roles in
the US. But, it's of course got some
real downsides as well. Some months,
maybe you'll make great money, and then
you can lose a client from one day to
the next, and you have to do everything
over again yourself. Finding the
clients, closing the clients, and then
actually doing the work. So, this option
is for you if you care more about
controlling your time than having a
predictable paycheck, and you don't mind
kind of the chaos of, you know, owning a
business and doing things like sales
calls. Okay, now the second type, and
for a lot of you guys, I think this is
the one that's the smarter play because
almost every company is in the same spot
right now. They know they need AI.
They've already got the tools, but they
have nobody inside who can actually make
it work for their specific business.
McKinsey found that 88% of companies now
use AI in at least one part of their
business, but only about a third of them
have scaled it past a few test projects,
and just 6% are what McKinsey calls high
performers, meaning they're actually
seeing a real measurable impact on their
bottom line from AI. So, paying for AI
turned out to be the easy part. Actually
using it is, of course, the bottleneck.
Accenture found that nearly two-thirds
of executives say their AI plans are
stuck because they don't have the skills
in-house to pull them off. And companies
are desperate to fix this. Manpower
Group surveyed 39,000 employers across
41 countries and found that AI skills
are now the hardest thing in the world
for companies to hire for, harder than
traditional IT and engineering for the
first time ever. And because of this,
the pay is climbing. PwC's latest AI
Jobs Barometer found that workers with
AI skills earn a 62% wage premium over
people without them. And that premium
has gone up every single year that
they've measured it. So, the second type
of consultant you can become is the
in-house consultant inside the company
that you already work for. You get a
stable paycheck, plus an advantage no
agency can ever touch because you
actually understand the business
already. You know the people, you know
the systems, and you know exactly where
the time's getting wasted. Now, of
course, the catch here is you're maybe
giving up some time and location
freedom, but you don't have to wait for
this position to open up somewhere. You
can kind of come in and create this role
for yourself. And if there's just one
thing that you take away from this
video, it should be this. Become the AI
person. Whether you're being the
freelancer or whether you're being the
in-house consultant, become the AI
person. This stuff is so new that nobody
has, you know, a 10-year head start on
you. Whether you graduated last month or
whether you've been at your company for
15 years. Everyone is basically starting
at the same line right now. So, learn
this stuff deeply, figure out where it
can actually help you, and become the AI
person. Because if you're early to this,
everything downstream, the clients, the
promotions, the raises, it all comes
looking for you. So, let me show you the
four steps to become that person. Now,
real quick, before we get into the how,
I put together a file with these exact
steps and everything that you need to do
at each one. So, you can download it and
just check things off as you go. You can
find this inside of my free school
community. The link's down in the
description. But, let's get back to the
video. Okay, step one is to pick one
painful problem. Open a doc and list
every manual task you or your team did
last week. And then circle the one that
eats the most hours. Say it's the report
you build from scratch every Friday.
Then, before you build anything, decide
on the metric you're trying to move. And
this is the whole consultant mindset.
Most people build automations because
they look cool or they've got a bunch of
little sub-agents and it might look good
as a LinkedIn post. But, a consultant
finds the constraint and designs a fix
that moves a specific number. So, let's
take that Friday report example. The
metric is the 4 hours it eats every
week. Whatever your problem is, name the
number before you touch anything.
Because that number is what you're
selling. You're selling the destination,
you're not selling the journey. And the
destination is always one of three
things: time saved, mistakes cut, or
money made. And real quick, just cuz I
have to throw this out there, before you
touch anything, only use AI tools that
your company allows and never put
company or customer data into something
that isn't approved. So, just be smart.
Anyways, now you've got one problem. And
you've got the number that you're trying
to move when you're solving this
problem. Step two is to build the fix
and then document it. And building the
fix doesn't mean you have to write code.
It means setting up Claude with the
right instructions and the real
documents behind the task. So, for this
Friday report, you give Claude maybe the
last few reports, those are some
examples, you know, you give it the
template, you give it a checklist of
where the numbers come from, and you
work with it until it nails the report
every single time, and you build skills
and instructions around this process. If
you can get Claude to do one task
reliably with real process docs, you're
ready. If you can explain things
clearly, if you can judge and critique
things and then give Claude feedback,
you're ready. Then, when you get
something you're happy with, record a
quick 2-minute before and after demo.
You know, "Hey, this used to take me 4
hours, but just watch it happen when I
run one command, and now it takes 10
minutes." Step three is to deliver it
and prove that the number actually
moved, the number that we picked before
you started building. So, now you can
say, "Hey, 4 hours down to just 20
minutes is 3 and 1/2 hours back every
single week." And that's the destination
that you had promised, and you actually
delivered on it, too. So, show it. Bring
it up in a team meeting or put it in
front of the business owner and ask one
question. Does anyone have a task they'd
want me to look at and see how I could
maybe automate it with AI. That question
will do more for you than any pitch and
every task you collect runs right back
through that same loop. You find the
constraint, you name the metric, you
build the fix, and then you prove that
the metric moved. Step four is where you
turn this into money. Your results are
now case study. If you're a freelancer,
take it to people who already know you
first and then cold outreach is the
volume play. And the motion I ran in my
own business was first build for free,
then I would do paid audits, and then I
would price the builds off that audit,
and then try to get them on a monthly
retainer, which is what fixes the income
roller coaster. And if you're in-house,
you take your stack of wins to your
boss, you frame every win as your boss's
win, and you make the role official.
Now, this may not happen immediately,
but when you do stuff like this, you are
creating an association in your
co-workers and in your boss's mind that
you are the AI person. Inevitably, you
will be in high demand. Companies are
already posting jobs like this under
titles like, you know, chief AI officer,
AI enablement lead. You're just becoming
that person before the posting even
exists. And if you don't have a job
right now, bring your one demo build
into interviews and you are the AI hire
that these companies can't find right
from the jump. So, all these numbers,
they're going to close deals or they're
going to get you promotions. So, now you
have a complete roadmap to becoming the
AI person and making money with Claude
in 2026. But, if you want to move
faster, you need to know exactly what to
learn because if you don't, you'll just
end up consuming information forever.
Inside my free community, you'll find
complete courses on Claude and resources
that'll help you skip weeks of learning.
And if you want to go deeper, you can
join my plus community where you'll get
courses on building your portfolio,
getting clients, and scaling your
one-person AI automation agency. The
link for both of these communities is
down in the description. But, anyways,
that is going to do it for this one. So,
if you guys enjoyed or learned something
new, please give it a like. That really
helps me out a ton. And as always, I
appreciate you guys making it to the end
of the video, and I'll see you all in
the next one.
Thanks, everyone.